le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
accédez aux loisirs à la culture et au
sport lorsque l'on est porteur de
handicap
c'est possible depuis 2003 le
département propose le dispositif pass
loisirs ces chèques s'adresse aux
personnes porteuses de handicap qui
peuvent les utiliser chez les
prestataires affiliés sur lille à saint
benoît l'association en distraction est
l'un des partenaires du pass loisirs ses
adhérents participent chaque semaine à
des activités sportives
[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde comme chaque matin
catherine rejoint les adhérents de son
association
parmi eux léonard qui n'a besoin que
d'une rampe pour se démarquer à la
pétanque ou bernadette tireuse émérite à
la carabine ou encore olivier dont la
déficience mentale n'entame en rien sa
stratégie au monopoly vous recevez un
milieu de 500 de ces personnes porteuses
de handicap font partie de l'association
bénédictine en distraction logique si la
station est de regrouper les
sympathisants afin de s'épanouir à
travers des activités de sports ou de
loisirs ont pour sentir les personnes en
situation d'handicap de l'isolément
voilà et puis peut-être de changer le
regard des gens aussi sur le handicap
est l'association est l'un des
partenaires du pass loisirs le
dispositif se présente sous la forme de
chèques
les porteurs de handicap en reçoivent
jusqu'à deux carnets parents dansent à
une valeur de 5 euros et le conte le
carnet à pour contenir ce dispositif a
été mis en place par le département en
2003 objectif permettre aux personnes
porteuses de handicap d'accéder aux
activités culturelles sportives et de
loisirs le pass loisirs si en fait un
moyen de rompre l'isolément des
personnes handicapées environ 80
personnes porteuses de handicap sont
bénéficiaires donc du patio que ça leur
permet justement de ces familles et de
son triangle par le bruit dans une soupe
a choisi à l'époque de l'épicier de
transport adapté et des non résidents de
toutes les festivités
il colle se trouvait sur lui
[Musique]
dans le cas de l'association bénédictine
l'échec permettent aux adhérents de
participer aux activités sportives chez
nous ça ouvre les adhésions
ça permet de payer les licences ainsi
dans le mois ont fait une ou deux
chantiers ça peut contribuer justement à
faire que les gens puissent pas
financièrement à travers le patois est
michel bénéficient de ce dispositif
en dehors de l'association elle en fait
souvent usage pour d'autres activités
ça me rend service des charbons 66 la
rue et puis consorts pour réviser un peu
pour hachette dès le petit déjeuner le
petit goûter et tout ça ne rend service
et plus basses ont vu se faire belle
pour aller se coiffer même ne pourrait
voir la musique parce que moi j'aime
bien aller au cinéma avec ce pass razzia
rôle de défense et consorts il ya le
pinceau à ziaya des transports ça nous
aide un petit peu financièrement une
aide financière mais pas seulement
dans ce cadre précis le pass loisirs
c'est surtout un ticket vers une vie
sociale épanouissante
[Musique]
tous les jeudis pendant les vacances
l'association a accès au gymnase amiral
bouvet à saint-benoît met en place pour
atteindre calme roquet bien les pouvoirs
et ne viser que le point stratégique au
point noir c'est avec passion que
catherine prodigue ses conseils
car les adhérents ne se contente pas de
tuer le temps certains se fixe de réel
objectif en participant à des
compétitions
huguette s'inscrire à peut-être à celle
du tir à la sarbacane depuis l'année
dernière a été ouvert en fait le cas de
championnat aussi et la licence coûte
quand même 34 euros le pass waziers
c'est le la porte pour accéder
à la demande de licence
[Musique]
la nouvelle saison approche donc mis
aimerait que deux tirs à mende
un certificat pour renouveler les
licences n'oubliez pas pour les
personnes que les noms cause de passe si
là pour contrôler et utiliser toutes que
les fassis ra ça qui est bénéficier du
pass aussi le doigt allait me dois pour
tous appartenir à l'association s'est
donné un nouvel élan à son existence
c'est d'être intégré dans la société
montrer nos capacités aussi parce qu'on
a quand même beaucoup de choses à donner
moi je pense que l'association a produit
beaucoup à certains de nos adhérents qui
sont bien souvent exclues du monde
ça permet
de vivre autrement
[Musique]
le pass loisirs est un dispositif
départemental qui permet aux personnes
porteuses de handicap d'accéder à des
activités culturelles sportives ou de
loisirs il se présente sous la forme de
chèques d'une valeur de 270 euros par an
valable chez le partenaire du dispositif
pour bénéficier du pass loisirs il faut
être titulaires de l'allocation adulte
handicapé ou de la pension d'invalidité
de catégorie 2 et 3 le dispositif
s'adresse aussi aux personnes de plus de
60 ans et aux enfants porteurs de
handicap
pour plus d'information vous pouvez
appeler au 0 800 00 8 952 ou consulter
le site du département au www.cglpl.fr
[Musique]